Good evening.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, although I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassa
Namo dasa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
So I thought we'd move on this evening to karma, action.
So all we can do, of course, is skim over it.
Again, I'll put on to the...
uh uh information with this particular little video uh again ajahn payuto who's this academic from thailand and he's also written a book on karma which is very very straightforward and shows you how intricate the whole teaching is now in this one here which is majima nikai number 135 the buddha is just laying down the sort of basic premise about
um karma so here we have now the brahmin student asuba todaya's son and he went to see the blessed one exchange greeting with him and after the courteous and amiable talk sat to one side master gossamer what is the cause and condition why human beings are seen to be inferior and superior
For people are seen to be short-lived and long-lived, sickly and healthy, ugly and beautiful, influential and uninfluential, poor and wealthy, low-born and high-born, stupid and wise.
So what is the cause, the condition?
So here now is your basic statement about karma.
Action and the consequences.
Beings are owners of their actions.
heirs of their actions they originate from their actions they're born of their actions they are bound to their actions in other words you can't separate yourself from your actions you cannot disown them having their actions as refuge not necessarily as a good refuge either it is action that distinguishes beings as inferior and superior so
You can't say I didn't mean to do something right.
It doesn't work in karma logic.
Every time we do something, whether it's something we think about, speak or act, there's always a moment of empowerment, there's always a moment of
taking something out of the potential into the actual.
So we saw that yesterday with dependent origination.
When something's a desire, nothing's happened, as soon as you activate it, as soon as you put your energy into it, identify with it, then it becomes an action.
And therefore we own all our actions, right?
Now here we're talking about a conventional sense of a person, right?
We're not into anata, not self.
It's very confusing.
We're just talking about just an ordinary person who makes decisions and therefore there are consequences.
They're heirs of their karma.
In other words, what we do now in the future, we will get the karmic consequence of it.
Of course, we can say that the self that commits the action is not the self that receives the consequence, right?
But as I say, let's put that bit about not self aside for the while.
They originate, they're born of their actions.
So your actions are actually many rebirths all the time, right?
Remember that we had that independence origination, the point where there's the identity, upadana, the grasping, and then the becoming.
So the becoming includes both the action and a new self, which is producing the action, okay?
They are bound to their actions.
So in other words, that's much the same as own, except that of course you run or you are under the control of your actions once you've done something.
And they're your refuge.
So hopefully they're good actions and they become something that you can depend upon for your goodness.
This is your punya, this is your goodness power.
uh of course if it's on the other side then it's uh it's badness power which isn't very good so it is action that distinguishes the inferior from the superior so in other words your whatever intention we have activated
unwholesome or wholesome, it'll have this consequent effect.
Now, the examples, well, what's his name again?
Subha.
Subha says, I do not understand in detail the meaning of the Master Gautama statement.
Could you please expound?
Listen and attend closely and I shall, says the Buddha.
Yes, sir.
So now again, we have to take these statements as broad statements
concerning wholesome and unwholesome action.
So some man or woman kills living beings, is murderous, bloody-handed, given to blows and violence, merciless to living beings.
Because of performing and undertaking such action on the dissolution of the body after death, they reappear in a state of deprivation, in an unhappy destination, in perdition, even in hell.
but if the if on the dissolution of the body after death they do not reappear in a state of deprivation and so on but instead come back as a into a human state then wherever they are born they are short-lived okay so
By the way, it's good karma.
You must have made some good karma to be reborn as a human being.
That's understand because it's not one of the lesser realms which are one of perdition.
So they include, you know, the animal realm, the realm of the hungry ghosts where one is never satisfied.
And of course, the hell realms, which are all sorts of degrees of human misery.
So again, remember, these refer to mental states, to certain conditions within us, and they also have a cosmological meaning for those who understand rebirth.
So to say that somebody is in an animal realm, they might be reborn into a place which is very dull-minded.
And therefore impossible to become liberated.
So remember, it's only in the human realm that the possibility of liberation is really actual.
In the higher realms, you're just too happy and you can't be bothered with it.
In the lower realms, you either haven't got the intelligence or you're in too much misery.
And of course, if you think about our lives, then of course, we pass through these realms.
But hopefully, because we've now established this mindfulness, we can always rise above, which means that whatever mental state that is, there's always the potential of insight.
So now the opposite is stated, of course, a man or woman abandoning, killing living beings, etc., because of performing and undertaking such action on the dissolution of the body, they reappear in a happy destination, even a heavenly world.
But if on the dissolution of the body after death, they do not reappear in a happy destination, etc., but instead come back to the human realm, then whatever they are reborn as, they will be long-lived.
So the Buddha here is making a connection between the length of our lives and how we behaved in the past.
Now, what we have to remember that these are very broad statements concerning the consequence of action.
What is not included in here is all the actions that somebody who has perhaps done murderous deeds
all the good actions they've done, which would mitigate consequences.
In the same way, somebody who has been saving lives might have done something also which is not quite saving lives, and that would also undermine the process of happiness.
So it's all, you have to see it all as a big mix.
It's a big mix.
But the general thing is that killing people has an effect on the length of your life.
So the next one is, of course, some man or woman giving to injuring beings with the hand, with a clod, with a stick, with a knife.
And because of performing and undertaking such action on the dissolution of the body after death, they appear also in a state of deprivation.
But if they come back in a human realm, they are reborn as sickly.
And the opposite, of course, you would be reborn as healthy.
So here there is some connection between the health, our health or lack of it,
good health or lack of it, depending on our cruelty to other beings.
Of course, there can be other reasons too, right?
This is where it gets all very complicated.
Just on that note, you might know or you might have heard of a Franciscan friar who was a contemplative in a monastery in Sicily called Father Pio.
now it would seem and this is all written up in magazines and stuff that an american pilot was flying over sicily and he'd not and he had an extra bomb that that he was going to just drop and as he passed over this particular town or village the monk actually appeared on his wing and asked him just to move a bit further before he dropped the bomb so of course uh being slightly shocked by that he he obeyed and did so
Years later, he picks up a magazine and there's this friar who'd sat on the wing of his plane.
So obviously he goes to see him.
And another story of Father Pio is that a man came for confession to try and absolve his sins and whatnot.
And he was blind.
And he asked Father Pio why he had gone blind.
And Pio was able to perceive that this was a consequence of him beating up his father.
So there are many, many stories like that, which are very difficult for us in our very scientific measure-everything age.
But we have to accept that some people can see things that we can't.
So then he goes on, third born healthy.
Now there are some, some man or woman is angry and irritable character.
When criticized a little, they're offended, become angry, hostile and resentful and display anger, hatred and bitterness.
And so much the same if they can be reborn into a state of deprivation, but if they're humans, then they're born ugly.
Now, of course, the face is ugly when you're angry and horrible.
So there's some connection there.
And of course, if you aren't like that, then you're reborn beautiful.
So there's something about the way we look which is determined in some small way by our mental states of anger, resentfulness, hostility, which manifests.
Here, some man or woman is envious.
uh they envy uh they resent they begrudge the gains honors the gains honor respect reverence and salutations and venerations received by others and because of this when they're reborn again it's always a bit of deprivation there because it's not very good uh but it as a human being they would they would uh find themselves uninfluential whereas somebody who does uh
who isn't envious, who isn't resentful, nor do they begrudge the gains and honours, honour, respect, reverence and salutations, etc., they will be reborn influential.
And then we have one which is to do with the attitude towards the spiritual life or religion.
some man or woman does not give food drink clothing carriages garland sense engines beds dwelling and lamps to the recluses or brahmins the recluses i probably don't need the garland sense and engines but maybe engines but the brahmins might do you see and they uh they will be born poor
Now, you'd think that anybody who's stingy would eventually be born poor, even if only they feel poor.
And of course, the opposite, they'd be wealthy.
And then some man or woman obstinate and arrogant who does not pay homage to one who should receive homage, does not rise up for one in whose presence they should rise up, does not offer a seat to one who deserves a seat, does not make a way for one who should be made way for, who does not honor, respect, revere and venerate those who should be honored, respected, revered and venerated.
So that sort of person will be reborn
in a low birth of course here we've got the caste system but we've also got the class system and so on and so forth and of course somebody who does honor where uh to give honor where honor is due uh they'll be reborn highly you see so the final one is um
a student some man or woman when visiting a recluse or brahmin does not ask venerable sir what is wholesome what is unwholesome what is blameable what is blameless what should be cultivated what should not be cultivated what kind of action will lead to my harm and suffering for a long time what kind of action will lead to my welfare and happiness a long time now because of uh because of not
asking these sorts of questions of not inquiring they will be reborn stupid one can sort of understand that if there's no sense of inquiry then that might stay with you on the other hand if you are that sort of person who does inquire about things you will be born wise
So then, of course, he restates all this in a slightly different way.
And there's a restatement of that basic formula.
Beings are owners of their actions, heirs of their actions.
They are born of their actions or originate from their actions.
They are bound to their actions.
Their actions are their refuge.
It is action that distinguishes beings as inferior and superior.
So in other words, our moral decisions and moral actions have a direct effect upon our bodies and minds and hearts.
And not only so in rebirth, in that rebirth process, but also just here in daily life.
So that is the understanding.
Now, tomorrow we'll see that it's a bit more complicated than that, but we'll leave it there for this evening, I think.
Yes.
and of course um the student suba today of sun uh is of course taken by this he says the usual pn at the end of every at the end of a successful uh conversion magnificent master gotama magnificent master gotama got the gotama has made the dharma clear in many ways as though he were turning upright what had been overturned revealing what was hidden showing the way to one who was lost
holding up a lamp in the dark to those who can see I go to master Gautama for refuge Adama and to the Sangha let master Gautama remember me as a lay follower who has gone to him for refuge for life so there's a bit of success for you so as I say tomorrow we'll we'll look at it a bit a bit closer so these
The teaching is that certain actions have a preponderance effect upon our lives.
But remember that they are in some way qualified or undermined or augmented by what we do on the opposite.
So if we do something quite unethical,
We also do some things that are ethical and these things begin to affect each other.
They balance each other out and the opposite, of course.
So I can only hope that this has not confused you even further.
It's a very difficult subject, karma, and it has all sorts of terrible questions.
Even so, I'm sure that by your continued investigations, you will indeed liberate yourself from all karma.
That's what we're looking at, liberation, sooner rather than later.
So we can begin our practice.